how cool are fats though the only
mammals that can fly they see with sound
and they're a great excuse for the crew
to dress me up like an idiot I hope you
guys are having fun anyway that's when
you're looking at a batwing you're
actually looking at a highly modified
hand surface area is a membrane
supported by long thin fingers by taking
to the air and exploiting niches other
mammals can't bats have become hugely
successful tallying over 1,000 species
across the globe in fact they make up a
quarter of all mammal species bats of
course use echolocation to pinpoint and
catch insects mid-flight that requires
some seriously frenetic maneuverability
like a fighter pilot on amphetamines but
it was only recently the scientists
discover how exactly bats are pulling
this off it turns out that a bats wings
are covered in microscopic sensory hairs
to detect changes in air currents so in
addition to using echolocation to make
sense of their world bats actually feel
their way through the air but not all
bats or after insects the biggest among
them eat fruit these are the accurately
named fruit bats the biggest of which
sport a wingspan of almost six feet
because fruit never evolved wings to fly
around and evade predators fruit bats
have no need for echolocation they just
use their sense of sight and smell the
weirdest among the fruit bats has to be
the hammer-headed bat only the male's
have that bizarrely shaped noggin which
amplifies vocalizations to attract
females
then the are throwing our ox and then
there are the vampire bats typically
these are going after things like pigs
and cattle but have been known to bite
sleeping human beings but unlike
vampires like me they don't actually
suck the blood they just give their
victim a nibble and lap at the wound
which makes me wonder why I had to wear
this stupid thing at all guys